on 11 22 22 I am officially
divorced Happily Divorced Valerie
Bertinelli's celebrating the single life
revealing she's officially divorced from
Tom Vitale it all is in like the old
adage says it's all in the journey it
truly is the actress
shares on Instagram while she was at the
airport on her way to see her son
Wolfgang Van Halen
at the airport
to go see Wolfie
and my large is called
the papers are all signed
they're about to be filed on 11 22 22 I
am officially divorced
finally
it's finally over
yes Valerie filed for legal separation
on November 24 2021 fast forward to May
and the hot and Cleveland star filed for
divorce citing irreconcilable
differences as the reason for her and
Tom's breakup the two were married over
10 years did you know go into marriage
thinking you're going to get a divorce
it sucks it sucks because you know
it's hard to not have a person in your
life that you thought you wanted to
spend the rest of your life with back in
June Valerie opened up to hold a copy
about her split from Tom and why she's
done looking for love I feel like I mean
I am going to be more than happy to be
happily divorced and spend the rest of
my life alone I'll be happy that way
well with my six cats and my dog and my
son and hopefully one day grandchildren
you don't think you'll look for love oh
God no because of the challenges that
I'm going through right now because
divorce sucks I can't imagine ever
trusting anyone again to let into my
life so I I have some trust issues that
I'm sure I'm going to have to get past
in the meantime Valerie's busy being a
proud mama I was Sophie's mom before
even Wolfie was you know famous so now
Wolfie's famous I feel like I'm latching
onto his coattails now the actress
recently gushed to E.T about watching
her son Wolfie following his late father
Eddie Van Halen's musical footsteps
after he performed at the Taylor Hawkins
tribute concert at Wembley Stadium
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it was spectacular yeah I've never been
so proud and I'm sure I'll be proud
again and Shane on the drums I was the
two of the moments that I was sobbing
[Music]